marco y sandra están viendo el plano
para su nueva casa que tiene una escala
de 80 a 1 el tamaño de la sala en el
plano es de 4 centímetros lo voy a
copiar de 4 centímetros un poco más
arriba
por cinco centímetros por cinco
centímetros cinco centímetros y la
pregunta es cuál es el área de la sala
en el mundo real nos interesa encontrar
esta área de acá sale esta área de acá y
para hacer esto lo primero que vamos a
tener que hacer es pasar estas
dimensiones a las dimensiones en el
mundo real y luego las vamos a
multiplicar para obtener el área déjame
empezar pasando las dimensiones a las
dimensiones del mundo real para eso
vamos a utilizar la escala de acá que es
80 a 1 y a veces puede ser un poco
confuso si tenemos que multiplicar o
dividir entre 80 pero aquí es muy claro
como aquí tenemos el plano que es más
chico que la casa estas dimensiones
quieren decir que por cada 80 unidades
en la casa tenemos una unidad en el
plano 80 centímetros en la casa son 1
centímetro en el plano y viceversa un
metro en el en el plano serían 80 metros
en el mundo real
saleh bueno entonces si tenemos aquí
cuatro centímetros para pasar
unidades del mundo real tenemos que
multiplicar por 80 por 80 y esto cuánto
nos da 4 por 80 es 320 de modo que este
lado mediría 320 320 centímetros en la
vida real y de modo similar este también
hay que multiplicarlo por 80 sería 80
por 5 centímetros y eso nos daría 400
400 esto es igual a 400 centímetros muy
bien con esto ya tenemos las dimensiones
en el mundo real para encontrar el área
de la sala tenemos que multiplicar las
sería 300 lo voy a poner más para acá
320 x tipificado por 400 déjame ignorar
los ceros por el momento 4 por 32 es 128
128 y ahora sí agregando estos tres
ceros tenemos 128 mil centímetros
lo voy a poner por acá 128 mil 128 mil
centímetros cuadrados
esos son un montón de centímetros
cuadrados a lo mejor para entender esta
área un poco mejor nos conviene pasarla
a metros cuadrados y para hacer esta
conversión déjame hacer un pequeño
recordatorio por aquí voy a poner un
cuadrado de un metro por un metro de
modo que su área es un metro cuadrado y
veamos que un metro son 100 centímetros
de este lado de este lado también estos
son 100 centímetros de modo que un metro
cuadrado tiene 100 x 100 centímetros
cuadrados es decir tiene 10 mil 10.000
centímetros cuadrados de esta forma para
convertir centímetros cuadrados a metros
cuadrados tenemos que dividir entre 10
mil entre 10.000 así que esta área
también la podemos poner como 12.8
metros cuadrados eso es una forma de
hacerlo pero también pudimos haber
trabajado con metros
del principio es decir pudimos haber
pasado estos 320 centímetros a 3.2 3.2
metros y de ahí multiplicar multiplicar
por 4 metros 4 metros que es lo
equivalente a 400 centímetros y la
multiplicación nos da 12 12.8 metros
metros cuadrados así que de cualquier
forma en la que lo pensemos o en la cual
lo trabajemos nos queda que el área de
la sala en el mundo real es de 12.8
metros cuadrados